In the previous
video, we generated
a CART tree with
three splits, but why
not two, or four, or even five?
There are different
ways to control
how many splits are generated.
One way is by setting a lower
bound for the number of data
points in each subset.
In R, this is called
the minbucket parameter,
for the minimum
number of observations
in each bucket or subset.
The smaller minbucket is, the
more splits will be generated.
But if it's too small,
overfitting will occur.
This means that CART
will fit the training set
almost perfectly.
But this is bad because then
the model will probably not
perform well on test
set data or new data.
On the other hand, if
the minbucket parameter
is too large, the model
will be too simple
and the accuracy will be poor.
Later in the lecture, we will
learn about a nice method
for selecting the
stopping parameter.
In each subset of
a CART tree, we
have a bucket of
observations, which
may contain both
possible outcomes.
In the small example we
showed in the previous video,
we have classified each
subset as either red or gray
depending on the
majority in that subset.
In the Supreme Court case, we'll
be classifying observations
as either affirm or reverse.
Instead of just taking
the majority outcome
to be the prediction, we
can compute the percentage
of data in a subset of
each type of outcome.
As an example, if
we have a subset
with 10 affirms and two
reverses, then 87% of the data
is affirm.
Then, just like in
logistic regression,
we can use a threshold value
to obtain our prediction.
For this example, we
would predict affirm
with a threshold of 0.5
since the majority is affirm.
But if we increase
that threshold to 0.9,
we would predict reverse
for this example.
Then by varying the
threshold value,
we can compute an
ROC curve and compute
an AUC value to
evaluate our model.
In the next video, we'll
build a CART tree in R
to predict the decisions
of Justice Stevens
and evaluate our model
using a ROC curve.